Rita let me start with you because of
everybody on this stage I feel like this
kind of began with you you were a fan of
Frederick Bachmann's book I'm curious to
know how you found it
well it was actually because it was the
movie first and it came to us in a DVD
not a CD as I said the other night
um and you know it was in one of those
folding packs that we used to get when
we would get DVDs and it was in the
foreign film section and along with
documentaries and live actions or
whatever and I read the little synopsis
and I thought this sounds interesting
and so we put it on I said let's watch
this movie and we put it on and 10
minutes in I looked over at Tom and I
was like we gotta make this movie and
you gotta play this because it's so
amazing it's like
but but the truth of it was that we had
been talking about
um comedy and I had said to Tom like why
don't you do more comedies I mean you
used to do so many you got your start in
comedy and he really said it's just so
much harder to find comedies that are
really about something that are grounded
in kind of a real way and I I I really
felt like that this would be that movie
so that was the inspiration and then I
read the book oh okay so Tom I was
looking back and I was like what is the
last kind of full-fledged comedy you've
done I was thinking maybe Larry Crown if
that qualifies yeah I'd say that yeah
that's a decade ago well the Nick the
nature of everybody knows the nature of
comedies have become essentially kids in
high school I I down at the office we
call it up oh another comedy about how
do I get laid you know uh and after a
while the the concept of of a comedy
that you sell as a comedy has to be a
number of things because it seems that
marketing people say we'll have to sell
it as a comedy
um I I I will take I take a degree of
pride in that I made a lot of movies
that are comedies that are also about
some very specific things that are
recognizable as opposed to
um a caper or an adventure or what have
you and I would say Larry Crown was one
of them that Thing You Do Was A comedy
nothing in common it was a comedy all
the Nora movies all the no all the Nora
Efron movies that are all much more
about uh community and a piece of I mean
uh certainly you know Nora's thing I'll
tell you this story when we made
um uh You've got mail
um uh we were she said she said you need
to read this as soon as possible and I
did and I said well this is this is this
is kind of amazing because this is
really about this thing that's going on
right now and um it's kind of like a
sequel to Sleepless in Seattle but it's
not so we'll just keep this in our
pocket and made a whole brand new move
she said yes we should we will make it
but we have to hurry up as because email
will be going away to some other
technology very quickly so with Nora
even knew that so but the you know a man
called ah OVA which we saw and I think
definitely what Dave and Mark did with a
man called Otto it is very funny but
it's not kooky or silly it is extremely
recognizable as the type of funny things
that we witness in our real lives every
day and that that brand of Comedy I
think is all it ends up being somehow
about the community how
um how there's there's stuff that
happens that just brings us joy at the
same right up against the stuff that
happens and and brings the sadness Mark
what I find really interesting we did a
chat the other night and what I'm about
to say it didn't occur to me because I
wasn't thinking hard enough here you are
a European director doing a U.S remake
of a European film
yes I mean but also probably you know
they thought I'm Swiss uh how funny can
he be but but that's not true because we
saw Stranger Than Fiction yes no and and
obviously David and I did Finding
Netherland together and I think that
that there's some humor in there and
some some emotion
but I I felt this collaboration working
together again and then working with
Rita and Tom and and and Tom and the the
assemble cast was very special because
ultimately it's you know it's about
Community it's a life-affirming film and
and ends with hope which is it's it's
life of of humanity which is so
important I think uh for me that and
special these days to keep installing
hope and and it's it feels that the film
was really grounded and life is the yin
and the young it's the dark and the
light it's you know funny and sad so I
think we all try to make the same movie
and it was a very very the collaboration
was very in sync absolutely David I'd be
curious to know on one hand I was
thinking if you're going to write a
screenplay that's based on obviously you
were also sourcing the book as I'm sure
as much as you were the Swedish film but
on one hand I thought it must be so
interesting to write a screenplay based
on something that there's already been a
screenplay written for because you have
the ACT structure there but that also
must make you feel like you want to do
your own thing so what were the
particular challenges on this one given
the fact that it had been a film before
well I had the luxury of Steel and the
good bits from from the original film
and then there were certain things that
I knew I had to translate over into an
American landscape and a political
system and legal system a lot of the
Swedish film had to do with socialized
medicine and that's how they were able
to move the neighbors out and force them
in and out of different housing so we
had to rethink that but that's all just
kind of like solving technical problems
really for me it was about characters
that I already recognized from I grew up
in the midwest in Michigan and for me
this was that character that it was my
dad Venera where you didn't talk about
your feelings and if you were in pain or
you were suffering you didn't share you
just said I'm doing okay I'm fine you
know but then it would leak out in other
ways and you would find your skin you
would find that you know even the best
intentioned person saying I'm fine would
start getting grumpy about the most
trivial thing and you'd think what are
you so sad about and and what what are
you so angry about and really it was
just discovering ways to find your way
into that person's psyche and go oh
that's not the problem this is the
problem and so I was all on board from
The Moment I Saw the film and then you
know talking to Rita and Mark it just
made perfect sense to me Dave wrote the
funniest line in the movie which is
spoken by an eight-year-old little girl
this is oh that's the goddamn stupid
dishwasher useless dishwasher yeah but
there you go that's that's that's well
that's the American touch right there
that that made it American instantly
yeah I do want to say uh that what I
thought was so extraordinary is that
Dave's first draft when it came in
we were gobsmacked because it was
so perfect and that and I said I I we
were like this just never happens this
just never happens you expect that
you're going to get there and then
eventually you'll you know work on it
and we did work on it but what was there
in that first draft was perfect
can we say though what was missing was
Hurricane Marisol this is what we needed
I mean we need yes tropical storm
Marisol absolutely yes don't we all fall
in love with not only Marisol but also
Mariana yes ah we do
I I would love to know I'm asking in
this innocence I don't know if this was
an offer if you had to audition how did
this become a reality for you how did
you find out about this film and what
got you excited about it
um well I I did this audition uh in a
hotel room you know holding my iPhone
and not really not knowing I loved the
scenes when I received them and I loved
exactly that one was a comedy and one
was uh emotionally challenging and and I
just love that and I I tried to be
honest and I tried to use what I had you
know the pots that I had in my kitchen
and and I I just threw it out I you know
I loved it and I I threw it out and I
would never imagine that
well she actually wanted to get the
audition back she's because she thought
it wasn't the right one it's the most
insane thing I've ever seen it's
literally Mariana and iPhone in a hotel
room and she's talking to herself and
her invisible husband an invisible Otto
and and she created the whole world like
it was it was unbelievable we couldn't
believe it
we're like I was sitting at home and and
Rita watched it like five times without
my knowledge and then she came in she
came in she came into the room where I
was and she said um
you have to see this
and I said what is it well it's on my
iPad you really have to see this and it
was and I did and cut two and the crazy
thing was when Francine maisler who the
casting director said to me you should
check out this Mexican actress Mariana
Trevino and so I I hope my computer was
beginning of casting there was only her
audition I said well one actress what
are you talking about I said just watch
her and I'm watching it said yeah I
don't think we need to see anybody else
yeah
as a music freak I'm just so excited to
share a stage with Thomas Newman who I'm
just such a gargantuan fan of
I'd be curious curious to know what were
the conversations that you had with Mr
Mark Forster about
what you were going to add to this
beautiful film
what were our conversations I don't even
remember I we just kind of started in I
think really and are you just starting
you have some successes some failures
and you just keep going right we did
just finished a film before that which
called White Bird was coming out next
year so we finished that and said Tom I
really would love to collaborate with
with it and mention it to Rita and Tom
and they said oh we know Tom we we're in
a carpool together so our kids were in
carpool together so we would take turns
so what are the odds right so that was
Truman Hanks that was in that carpool by
the way and and then Tom uh for the
opening credits he suddenly started he
had he wrote a piece of music for that
and he said do I have this other idea
and he started this was this little bit
of a spaghetti western tune suddenly and
I said this is brilliant this is a
spaghetti western in this and it's like
suddenly I felt that was the right tone
for Otto because yeah
I think the Noose was a kind of gave
that idea a bit Yeah but it did the idea
did come late and you know as I said the
other night a lot of times the best
ideas are the the ones that come in last
uh Tom I want to end with a question for
you because I feel like this whole
concept of not in my backyard is
something that's been part of the
American Experience for better or worse
for decades but did you Marvel at this
film's kind of increasing relevance over
the last nine or so months oh dear funny
yeah I I must say we I I think we might
have been look you can't make an
altruistic movie I mean you can't say oh
we're gonna send out a message on this I
think that what we all saw certainly in
in the original what we talked about
again and again and again and again was
the undeniable truth that everybody can
experience it if they're open to it and
that's the power of community and the um
uh I think the beauty of it all really
does stem from these noisy
Mexican family that is moving across the
street and on one hand the most if you
were going to pay to the cynicism that
seems to be the default position of an
awful lot of media or attention would
say well there goes the neighborhood but
the reality of people learning to look
out for one another what better
neighborhood could anybody live in than
one in which everybody can knock on the
neighbor's door and say either I need
help with something or ask a question do
you need help with something it's
undeniable and I look I don't wanna I
don't want to become Johnny America here
but uh uh this is what I have witnessed
in my 66 years as an American that
that's what people actually do it's more
glamorous and I think it's easy to to to
celebrate and capture and go over and
over again to the to the conflicts and
the outrage that can go on but in fact
act if you're if you live on a on a
block you want to have neighbors like uh
like Marisol and Tommy really do Mark
and Tom and Rita and Mariana Dave thank
you so much thank you Dave thank you
thank you for coming tonight thank you
so much thank you thanks so much